david
is in washington d.c hi david welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi gentlemen thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i have a question my wife and i have
a 529 plan for our son
in the state of virginia and he's got
one and a half years left until leaving
for college
we think it's pretty much fully funded
so we're only putting small amounts into
it now but we're concerned that maybe
our distributions are a little too
aggressive now so we've got like 78
percent
in stocks 18 in bonds 4 in cash
and we wanted to just kind of know
should we back off of that a little
either now or next year or as we head
into college
how much is in there
we have in there right now
165 000. okay well done
congratulations that's fabulous that is
great
very fortunate and and when you say
stocks bonds and cash you're talking
about you've got
it's a mutual fund selection you're not
in individual stocks or bonds
that's correct we have uh mutual funds
uh
through american funds yeah okay okay
yes well
here's the thing bonds have an inverse
relationship as you probably know david
to the interest rate market
so uh as interest rates go down
bonds prices go up interest rates have
been
unbelievably low for an unbelievably
long period of time
there's not a lot of places they're
going to go but up
in terms of major moves in interest
rates in the next five years okay
while your kid's in school and so
while bonds are typically pitched if you
read the
standard financial planning writing
people pitch bonds as a stabilizer in a
portfolio
in an extended low interest rate
environment my
personal conviction is that they are a
destabilizer because i think as interest
rates tick up those bond prices are
going to go down
you're going to lose your butt on that
part of the portfolio
and so it's while it's supposed to be
more safe
than the than the stocks i don't think
it is in this current world
personally uh so you can do what you
want to do but you called us so that
that's an opinion it worked probably
worth what you paid for it
i don't i consequently i don't own any
bonds right now
matter of fact i've never really used
bonds much in my investing at all
unless they're in a balanced fund or
something like that but so
then the question just becomes do you
want to be in cash or do you want to be
in growth stock type mutual funds
uh for the next three and a half four
and a half years because the
bulk the a piece of that money is not
going to come out for five
for four years right that's right
correct so
i'm probably going to stay depending on
how
worried you are about the stock market
uh i'm gonna
the less worried you are i'm gonna stay
heavy heavy heavy in in the
in the in the uh growth stock mutual
funds and
a little bit of cash and the more
worried you are the more i would be
about cash but i don't think it's
unsophisticated
as a matter of fact it's just a
different way of thinking it's a
different critical thinking set
to avoid bonds number one and to number
two to say
ah the risk represented by the market is
not so substantial
on stocks that it's going to drive me
crazy well and the mindset dave i think
this year has or
this past year i keep to keep going
backwards here uh the past year has
shown us as we looked at what happened
to the stock market in march
and then how it rebounded and came back
in october yeah you know for us to make
sure that we remember it's the
long-range view
right and and i think that is that i'm
going to keep beating that drum of
riding the roller coaster long-range
view look at what's going on don't
listen to what people are saying
watch what's happening yeah um i mean
on the short term the only thing that
disturbs me for the stock market's sake
more than anything else is just the
level of political unrest oh i agree
that's a short term um i mean if you
believe that the political unrest is
going to lead to
the uh the nation unraveling then you'd
get out of the stock market completely i
don't believe that
but the stock market does not like
an unpredictable world
it likes a predictable world even if
it's a liberal world or a conservative
world right
a democrat or a republican it just let
me know out what it is
and i can predict it and when when
things aren't predictable so
if a war springs up across the world of
geopolitical it doesn't like that
this crap going on in washington on both
sides of the aisle
right is astronomically crazy when the
cities were burning last summer
right without getting into reasons or
whether agreement or anything like that
the stock market doesn't like it right
well it's a living breathing thing as
you've told
people for years and because it's living
and breathing it's got feelings
and so the stock market has feelings and
so imagine if too much unrest or too
much this or that happens
there is going to be a reflection at
some point yeah it's when people are
worried it shows up right that's really
what it comes down to
because it depends depending on what
they're worried about so anyway all that
to say david
i personally if you if it was my kid
i would be heavy in stocks i'd be light
to none in bonds
and to the extent you're worried i would
crank up my percentage in cash
uh to the extent you're worried about
the next two years
of volatility but if the thing goes down
10
that would be almost that'd be one of
the biggest drops in 12 months in the
history of the stock market
if it went down 10 and that would be
sixteen thousand dollars
doesn't keep your kid from going to
school no so you're not really playing
with huge huge risk you're not gonna
have a situation where you lose
fifty percent of your money that has
occurred only two times in the entire
history of the stock market
and i do not see that item on the
horizon it could be there but i don't
see it well and let's talk real quick
here about obviously with
student education and going to college
you've got 165 000 that you put away
you know as you start to look in state
at 10 000 a year
you've covered out-of-state tuition is
22 000 a year
and private tuition is around 36 000. so
you know you look at the dollar amount
that you all have set aside david you
all have done a fantastic job
of being prepared now do finish the job
i guess is what i'd say
uh help your young person make a smart
decision and don't pick a school based
on a sports team
and don't pick something based on a
mascot let's pick one pick something
that is fiscally responsible
that you can pay cash for there you go